well all this gray weather comes as Las
Vegas's biggest convention starts
tomorrow the Consumer Electronics Show
back to full strength after years of
coronavirus restrictions but this year
CES still does include some new testing
requirements organizers are requiring
negative covid tests from people
arriving from China Hong Kong and Macau
tomorrow the center is for Disease
Control is implementing a similar policy
as those countries China for example
battle an increase in cases despite that
this CES is expected to be very busy
once again visitors for more than 150
countries are here in town showcasing
the latest in Tech Candace Charles has a
sneak peek
exhibitors from all over the country
will be here to show the latest in
technology it's all presented by CTA and
I'm joined by CTS Ali free thank you so
much for joining us tell us what's new
this year well we are thrilled to be
back the new thing is the excitement and
momentum we've got 3 200 exhibitors
we're expecting about a hundred a
thousand attendees showcasing the latest
in digital Health Therapeutics wellness
it's all here this week and we can't
wait to get started I also hear that be
an autonomous race car which is really
cool we're seeing how that's going to be
going but besides that like you said you
got a little bit of everything including
the dozie Cozy now I'm a purple mattress
so how would this help me get a little
bit more of an amazing sleep yeah so the
dozie Cozy is an AI activated smart
pillow so you put this sensor on your
waistband and it knows how you're
sleeping are you on your side are you on
your back and then it adjusts to what
you need so maximizes your neck Comfort
make sure that you're getting that deep
REM sleep that you need plays into the
digital Health story that we're seeing
pervasive throughout the show floor this
week absolutely you're speaking my
language more sleep is needed now this
is something that's really cool too it's
been a big conversation about how to
keep in contact with their child without
getting a cell phone so tell me about
this exactly I mean as a parent you're
concerned about your kids you want to
make sure they're safe and protected at
all times so this is a smart watch it
has GPS tracking you can set safe zone
so you know when they go in or out of
the safe zones there's a camera that you
can see that's really cool look guys say
hi and say hello it's just a really cool
product to have one of the many that
will be here on the floor thank you so
much Ali for chatting with us you guys
it all kicks off on Thursday right here
at the convention center like I said so
much to see and do a lot of fun we got
to cover with details on our website
8newsnow.com for now from the convention
center I'm Candace Charles it is now